prospection turc en méditerranée
orientale interventions dans les
conflits libyen et syrien soutien à
l'azerbaïdjan au haut karabagh les
sujets de discorde entre la turquie et
l'union européenne se sont multipliées
l'année dernière dans le sillage des
attaques virulentes de recep tayyip
erdogan à l'encontre de ses voisins
mais depuis le ton a changé du côté
d'ankara
le président turc a même ouvert la porte
la semaine dernière à un apaisement des
relations une dynamique confirmée ce
lundi par mevlut cavusoglu
le ministre turc des affaires étrangères
recevait son homologue allemand il y à
une atmosphère positive dans les
relations turquie union européenne
surtout parce que même si les
conclusions du sommet de décembre ne
nous ont pas satisfaits nous l'avons
pris comme un signal positif et nous
avons rendu la pareille et avons
commencé à prendre des mesures positives
preuve de la bonne volonté du
gouvernement turc la proposition de
pourparlers avec la grèce à partir du 25
janvier au sujet des explorations
pétrolières en méditerranée orientale
suite aux sanctions prononcées par
l'union européenne la turquie a accepté
de relancer le dialogue
après plus de quatre ans d'impasse une
initiative remarquée et appréciée côté
européen
sur cette question je peux dire que je
parle non seulement au nom du
gouvernement fédéral allemand mais aussi
au nom de nombreux collègues au sein de
l'union européenne
c'est depuis longtemps le premier pas
vers une solution diplomatique et un bon
signal pour la stabilité de la région
la normalisation des relations avec
l'union européenne pourrait être motivée
par l'arrivée de joe biden à la maison
blanche
l'élection du démocrate marque la fin de
la politique plus tolérante de donald
trump or envers la turquie un changement
de dynamique auquel recep tayyip erdogan
doit s'adapter